so sit back and enjoy my delicious
simple suppers one of my essential
mantras for becoming a better cook is
it's all about building your confidence
and the way to do that is with practice
the key is to have a repertoire of easy
dishes you want to cook it and eat time
and time again and soon you'll be on
your way to becoming a kitchen demon my
first dish keeps it simple but delivers
big-time on flavor so it should have
become a regular quick supper fix spicy
tuna fish cakes I love this recipe why
because it turns this humble ingredient
a can of tuna into something delicious
just open up and drain the tuna into a
sieve just like leaf like that then
press it too hard otherwise we'll dry
out the tuna now these are water
chestnuts just slice it nice and thin
you can buy them anywhere any
supermarket chestnuts and fresh ginger
give her that rough skin on the outside
by grating the ginger you get to get all
that very nice sort of juice and take
your spring onions and just slice on an
angle I like the texture of the water
chestnuts with a spring onion will touch
your fresh coriander lovely next remove
the seeds from a chili to reduce its
heat without losing any flavor and
finely chopped chilies and kaffir lime
leaves roll them up nice and tight run
your knife down the center once and just
chop that makes the fish cake nice and
fragrant touch of salt touch of pepper
fish sauce just lightly seasoned tuna to
bind all those wild ingredients 2 whole
eggs and give that a nice little whisk
and then add your eggs see hands in
there and start mixing get the mixture
roll it and the hand with the palm pad
and a nice to cook add a little ground
nut oil to a hot pan at the face of a
clock we're gonna go from 12 all the way
around first one in these fish cakes
only take a few minutes to cook so
keeping track of the order they go in
the pan means you know which one to turn
first
[Music]
we've had a nice gentle little shake
make sure that nothing's sticking to the
bottom spatula two fingers on top
turn them over beautiful that crackling
noise is something always one because
the tune is already cooked so we just
lightly fine them to get a nice crisp
outside and gently take them out
smell incredible let them sit there I
want to make a really nice delicious
simple dipping sauce start off little
pinch of sugar fish sauce two
tablespoons that gives it the saltiness
1 tablespoon of rice wine vinegar and
some fresh lime juice squeeze your fresh
coriander lots of coriander and then
give that your mix and then you have the
most amazing spicy tuna fish cakes who
would have thought something as
delicious that can come out of a can a
simple supper in minutes that's so
mouth-watering it easy and delicious you
guaranteed to cook it again and
when it comes to simple cooking there
are two basic bits of kit I'm never
without that will save you time and
effort in the kitchen I grater and a
peeler these swivel peeler a stainless
steel one absolute incredible is almost
like a lifesaver in the kitchen because
they are so quick so light swivel blade
so got so much more flexibility you
actually go around the vegetable and we
call it speed peeler in a professional
kitchen because it does literally
absolutely rapidly peels your vegetables
you have minimal waste we just got from
a couple of quid and upgrade for
everything from peeling bread to find a
slicing cheese and making shards of
chocolate a good comfortable grip and a
sharp stainless steel plate you should
always work fast the box grater is
another great versatile kitchen tool now
with his plane for poor grating
vibrating and super fine as well as
blades for slicing it's perfect for
everything from puring ginger and
nesting lemons to shredding onions super
small so they can can rise in a flash
I'll be sure to get a solid handle to
hold it firm it's got such volume inside
it doesn't crush something up so I
always prefer the grates onto a tray or
into a bowl so you don't have to move it
again grating onto the board you've
always got to lift it up and place it in
so place the greater into Bowl and great
to simple but essential speedy bits of
kit guaranteed to make your life in the
kitchen easier bread is a brilliant base
for delicious superfast lunches and
suffers here are three of my deliciously
simple recipes that transform a humble
bit of bread into a gastronomic treat
first up flatbeds with fennel and feta
and olive oil to a flatbread
[Music]
then place in a hot frying pan and toast
it'll crisp and golden on both sides
these deliciously versatile breads are
made without yeast and are available in
good supermarkets and local Middle
Eastern shops next thinly sliced fresh
fennel and scatter over the toasted flat
right
then turns aromatic fennel seeds in a
hot dry pan and sprinkle on top
come-over wonderful tendon feta cheese
finished with a drizzle of sweet and
sticky pomegranate molasses
bread transformed before your eyes
flatbread with fennel and feta simple
delicious and ready to eat in minutes my
next recipe that turns a hunk of bread
into a stunning dish is bruschetta with
garlic tomatoes capers and pecorino
[Music]
start by slicing a baguette diagonally
to hear a large surface area so it holds
more of the delicious topic drizzle the
bread with extra-virgin olive oil
then place it all side down on to a
scorching hot griddle when the bread is
beautifully charged remove and rub with
a pill clove of garlic band attention to
the edges
next half sweet cherry tomatoes and
above the juices into the toasted garlic
bread
then simply crush on top
next slice the scatter over tangy caper
berries and use a veg peeler to add
shavings of salty pecorino cheese and
finally drizzled with extra virgin olive
oil and add a twist of black pepper
[Music]
fantastic fresh flavors in the flesh of
a griddle pan
toast has never tasted so good
[Music]
perfect for a simple light supper or
easy lunch my next dish is a kundalini
bean crostini with anchovy and olive oil
[Music]
first the topping the olive oil in a
frying pan
had 10 cannellini beans along with the
juices
one sees it gently mash the beans with a
fork
sliced black olives roughly chopped
parsley
and a splash of sherry vinegar
season
and legal a gentle heat
next hop FSG butter and splash with
extra virgin olive oil
he's a griddle pan that will smoke him
and toast the bread all side down
pressing into the pan to char evenly to
serve top the toasted ciabatta with a
killeen bean mixture
and finish with chopped anchovies
packed with bold flavors so easy you can
always make it blindfolded ready under
10 minutes but eaten in seconds
three different breads three fantastic
recipes proof that even when you press
for time you can still eat like a king
because
these are my perfect TV dinners next up
my guide to getting the best ingredients
for your money my shopping mantra is
very simple first rely on your senses
make sure whatever you're buying it
looks smells and really feels good and
if you get the chance to taste it before
you buy it then do it second is to
recognize that knowledge is absolutely
crucial the more you know about where
your ingredients are from and how they
produce the better so that we scared ask
lots of questions and learn and when you
want a simple supper
perhaps a perfect to use in your cooking
they add vibrancy and amazing depth of
flavor and once you get the hang of them
they are so quick and simple to use and
one woman who really knows these chef's
best friends is expert herb grower
Loraine Melton I love herbs I love the
way you can cook with him I love the
smell of them she's been grown an
incredible array of herbs in the wet
Cambridgeshire countryside for over 20
years and can smell obey from a basil at
50 paces we grow about a hundred and
fifty varieties of herbs it's always
interesting to grow new varieties see
what they taste like see what they smell
like it gets a bit addictive after I out
broadly speaking you get harder herbs
and softer herbs softer herbs and things
like Parsi as a rocket coriander we grow
two main types of paths we've got flat
leaf parsley and curly parsley
flavor-wise I think they're very similar
although a lot of people would say that
the flat leaf parsley has got a stronger
more aromatic flavor this is your common
basil sweet Genovese this is a purple
variety called Reuben with a Greek basil
Thai basil holy basil when you're
looking for a basil you want a bright
fresh basil nice leaves no blemishes and
nice strong stems it's got a lot of oils
in it and it's very strong smelling it
just tastes of summer basil Lorraine
certainly knows her stuff and she's
right soft herbs are delicate so for
maximum flavor always use them at the
end of cooking or simply add as they are
to cold dishes here are my top five soft
herbs that could never live without
basil as Lorraine says it comes in many
types all with an amazing sweet pungent
flavor great Blitzen pesto's sprinkled
whole over mozzarella and showing its
versatility it even makes a wonderful
ice cream
parsley beautifully earthy and intensely
fresh used both the leaves and the stem
for great depth of flavor in savory
dressing soups and salads coriander for
an amazing hint of citrus often using
thai dishes kinder is perfect and
curries and chutneys but it bruises
easily so treat it with care tarragon a
staple of French cooking
this has long soft green leaves and a
distinct and the sea flavor great with
chicken or enriched creamy sauces and
finally chervil both modern sweet a
perfect pairing with fish an incredible
mix simply with melted butter for a
quick sauce those are my favorite soft
herbs what about the hard ones tends to
be a more woody France things like thyme
rosemary they've got your common time
which is your ordinary general bog
standard cooking time and then you've
got things like lemon thyme we do an
orange thyme which is actually one of my
favorites
it smells like time but it's got a deep
sort of musky scent as well it's just
gonna give you a slightly different
flavor in your dish part herbs like
thyme could take more intense cooking
than soft herbs so the great in stews
roasts or pan frying choose the right
one and you can add wonderful depth of
flavor to your dishes here are my top
five I use day in and day out
rosemary amazingly robust with great
bittersweet green leaves
it's a classic paired with lamb
delicious sprinkled over speciality
breads like focaccia or great as
toppings for fruity sorbets Lorraine's
favorite time a heady aromatic pungent
herb which has delicious flavor to a
Sunday roast it's amazing with wild
mushrooms and is perfect in marinades
Paragon Oh warm and full of delicious
aromatic oils a staple of great Italian
dishes and perfect sprinkled on pizzas
or in pasta sauces sage a strong tasting
hub with a deliciously bitter flavor
incredible in stuffings and with rich
meat like pork or duck
finally they bitter sweet and spicy it's
delicious simmered in soups stocks and
risottos and just as good dried or fresh
growing herbs is a lot easier than
people think it is on Windsor boxes in
balconies it's greatly from a just open
your window put your hand out and snip
some off when you're out looking for her
is make sure that life's of healthy no
blemishes stems look strong they should
just spring back so nice spring you sort
of herbs smell obviously is quite
important not all things smell but
obviously if you think it's one that's
gonna smell like lemon thyme it should
have a nice fresh lemon scent and
obviously the final one is taste you can
tip a bit off and taste your hopes and
you can see what they taste like them
whether bought from a supermarket or
picked from your window box herbs a
great way to add fresh flavors to your
dishes perfect for delicious simple
suppers
even if you got a super busy lifestyle
it doesn't mean missing out on delicious
desserts they just have to be simple to
make when it comes to cooking at home
puddings should always be a pleasure and
never a chore and homemade puts are 100%
guaranteed to impress my next recipe has
only two main ingredients but simplicity
doesn't mean food can taste
out-of-this-world
incredible griddle pineapple with spiced
caramel if you make it a dessert the 102
is gonna be quick and easy this
sumptuous delicious griddle pineapple
fits the bill perfectly
pineapple way of testing is nice and
ripe the top of the leads come out
perfect ready to go
always cut a pineapple with a serrated
edge knife slice off at the bottom turn
it back over and slice the top part now
keep that for later look at the core the
center of the pineapple and slice down
directly in half slice that in half take
each quarter and slice them it smells
incredible lay down flat just slice that
core off so you've got this perfect sort
of boat on pineapple slice underneath
but stop as you get right at the end
slicing around the skin will make the
pineapple easier to eat but leaving your
TAS gives you more control as it cooks
next peter griddle pan as hot as you can
start off in the corner push it down
so really mark the pineapple two minutes
on each side and then just turn them
really nice color on there oh that
beautiful I'm gonna sprinkle them with a
little touch of sugar it's gonna glaze
them now slice the top they gather
beautiful glazed slices of pineapple
next up the spiced caramel now start off
with your pan nice and hot
sprinkle four tablespoons of sugar in
there
just flatten it then add the seeds from
a fresh vanilla pod in a small dusting
of Chinese five-spice never stir camel
let it sort of bubble and transform you
she goes now I've got the color I want
it that's the perfect color off with the
gas in with a butter and then couple
tablespoons of cream lovely and give
that a little whisk add the rest of your
cream nice
and just drip a spicy camel over your
pineapple hmm Wow
simple elegant and seriously impressive
brittle pineapple with spiced camel a
delicious treat all to yourself that
tastes even better shared
next my tricks of the trade and kitchen
tips first up the proper way to chop
fresh herbs to get maximum flavor
chopping herb the secret is to chop them
not bruise them now basil this is a soft
herb so treat it with some respect when
people go mad chopping herbs all the
goodness comes out on the board
I want the goodness left inside the
basil place them all inside one another
with the largest leaf at the bottom and
it's almost like rolling a cigar large
one at the bottom small ones in the
center and then look place them down
together just roll them nice and gently
don't bruise them step one roll ready to
slice sharp knife imperative fingers
tucked in the bottom part of your
knuckle is the guide between you and the
herbs that their tops you can cut your
finger really important to get
comfortable the knife and just practice
rolling the knife across the board and
relaxing that wrist it's all in the
wrist action
so herbs up fingernails tucks underneath
and just up and down up and down
and there you have a chop basil that's
not bruised and smelling very fragrant
right coriander so you get the bunch of
coriander hold it down and just lightly
shave the leaves off the stalls bunch
them up together and then just again let
the knife do the work took the
fingernails in and just chopped once and
once only don't hack it just chop it you
can always identify when you bruise the
herb when you've removed the herbs off
the board as a big green patch mmm full
of flavor and none of the goodness is
left on the chopping board a great tip
for using leftover herbs simply chop
finely mix into butter roll up in cling
film and freeze
[Music]
then when you want a Hardy hit cut into
slices and melt over steaks chicken or
veg
asparagus is great for simple supper to
prepare always remove the lower woody
stem by gently bending and the asparagus
will snap at the perfect point then boil
steam and serve with a little of my herb
butter
for a crack in softball day simply place
your egg in boiling water and a splash
of vinegar and cook for exactly eight
minutes then plunge into ice water
the vinegar helps the shell peel off
easily and the ice water stops the egg
from cooking giving you the perfect
runny yolk
four plus three salad dressings simply
add the ingredients into a jam jar screw
the lid on tightly and shake to combine
in seconds there's no need to wash up a
whisk and the jars ready-made to store
any leftovers
follow my ultimate cookery course
bursting with valuable lessons top tips
and 100 recipes to stake your life on
and you literally been cooking yourself
into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the App Store for
details go on get cooking